et on le disait la visite du président
américain intervient à un moment décisif
sur le terrain les Russes semblent être
à la manœuvre dans l'Est leur offensive
de printemps aurait même commencé c'est
ce que disent plusieurs experts Pauline
Godard bonjour on vous retrouve depuis
zapporja vous êtes une de nos envoyer
spécial en Ukraine les annonces
américaines d'abord
sont les bienvenus bien sûr elles ont
été bien accueillis par les Ukrainiens
où elles sont bien sûr très importantes
ces annonces pour les Ukrainiens vous le
rappelez vous le rappeliez Joe Biden a
promis 500 millions de dollars d'une
nouvelle aide militaire et bien c'est
très important puisqu'il va fournir des
munitions pour les lance-roquettes des
missiles antichard des radars de
surveillance orientie aériennes volent
qui ne cesse de le répéter depuis le
début de la guerre il lui faut toujours
plus d'armes et bien pour voir combattre
la Russie et gagner cette guerre le
président ukrainien réclame aussi des
avions de chasse mais pour le moment Joe
Biden n'a pas répondu de façon positive
à cette demande le président américain a
déclaré que les États-Unis resteraient
aux côtés de l'Ukraine aussi longtemps
que nécessaire la liberté n'a pas de
prix à répéter et expliquer le président
Joe Biden il faut dire que c'est inédite
qui est vraiment très symbolique c'est
la première fois que Joe Biden se rend
en Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
et dans quatre jours cela fera un an que
le début de
russe de l'invasion russe à grande
échelle en Ukraine à débuter c'est aussi
pour montrer à Vladimir Poutine et bien
que les États-Unis et que les
Occidentaux se tiennent toujours aux
côtés des Ukrainiens coûte que coûte ici
notamment les médias ukrainiens ont
souligné le fait que cette visite était
d'autant plus symbolique et bien car
elle était très dangereuse et Joe Biden
n'a pas hésité à prendre ce risque à
venir malgré le danger malgré son âge
aussi à venir ici en Ukraine pour se
tenir aux côtés des Ukrainiens les
personnes avec qui nous avons pu
discuter ici à zapuridja nous ont dit
être très reconnaissant vis-à-vis de Joe
Biden de cette visite et que bien sûr
c'est nouvelle annonces pour cette
nouvelle aide militaire de 500 milliards
de dollars étaient bien sûr la bienvenue
500 millions de dollars pour l'instant
en tout cas les Ukrainiens réclame les
Ukrainiens qui réclament donc de
nouvelles armes on ne sait pas encore
dans le détail ce qu'il sera ce qui sera
fourni aux
Ukrainiens par les Américains Pauline
nous avait tourné é vous il y a peu à
quelques kilomètres de la ligne de front
et vous pouvez témoigner de la vétusté
de certains matériels d'où l'importance
donc de cette aide américaine
oui tout à fait nous étions il y a
encore deux jours dans le don basse à
environ 7 km de la ligne de front alors
je pourrai pas vous dire exactement où
nous étiez pour nous étions pour des
raisons de sécurité pour les temps qui
c'est avec qui nous avons pu filmer ce
reportage ils nous ont montré les chars
avec lesquels ils combattaient ce sont
en grande majorité des t64 il date de
l'Union soviétique et c'est vrai qu'on a
pu voir qu'ils étaient très vétustes
aucune nouvelle technologie à
l'intérieur et c'est militaire nous ont
confié passer environ 70% de leur temps
et bien à réparer ses chars plutôt qu'à
combattre et à passer seulement 30% de
ce temps à combattre et ils aimeraient
bien passer plus de temps sur le terrain
sur la ligne de front ils nous ont dit
attendre désespérément la livraison de
ces chars c'est Charles léopards de
notamment qui ont été promis par les
Occidentaux à l'Ukraine ils ont ils ont
expliqué que grâce à ces chars qui ont
justement cette nouvelle technologie
dont ils ont besoin ils pourront être
beaucoup plus rapides et beaucoup plus
efficace sur le front pour pouvoir
repousser l'ennemi et enfin rentrer chez
eux et être avec leur famille voilà ce
que nous ont confié ces soldats et on
verra votre reportage dans les prochains